aquí tenemos un paralelogramo abc de y
lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
platicar una forma para encontrar el
área de este paralelogramo en general en
el vídeo pasado ya platicamos cómo
hacerle cuando el paralelogramo es un
rombo un rombo es un paralelogramo
verdad y en este vídeo vimos que bastaba
multiplicar las diagonales y dividir el
resultado entre dos sin embargo no todos
los paralelogramo son rombos así que no
para todos los paralelo gramos funciona
multiplicar sus diagonales y dividir
entre dos déjame empezar con lo que sí
sabemos acerca de los paralelo gramos de
cualquier paralelogramo y eso es que
este lado el lado ave es paralelo al cde
y de hecho miden lo mismo lo voy a
marcar así y el bc es paralelo al ade y
también miden lo mismo entonces este es
paralelo a este a este de acá y también
miden lo mismo lo voy a marcar con estas
dos rayitas vale muy bien ahora para
determinar el área de abc de vamos a
hacer un pequeño truco vamos a trazar
una diagonal vamos a poner la diagonal
a ver si me queda derechita ahí está y
con esto lo que sucede es que se forman
dos triángulos el adc y el cb ah y ya
hemos platicado en otros vídeos que
estos dos triángulos son congruentes y
lo hemos demostrado pero como el
argumento es muy sencillo déjame volver
a darle mira estos dos triángulos adc y
cb a comparten la longitud de este lado
porque cde es igual a ave la longitud de
este lado porque bc es igual a ade y
además comparten la longitud de la
diagonal entonces tienen sus tres lados
congruentes y por lo tanto son
congruentes déjame apuntarlo por aquí
tenemos que el triángulo
b c es congruente es congruente al
triángulo se ve a al triángulo
de a por criterio por criterio por
criterio de congruencia claro criterio
lado lado lado tres lados iguales
entonces son congruentes y esto funciona
porque si son congruentes entonces
tienen exactamente la misma área
entonces cómo vamos a utilizar eso pues
bien lo que nosotros queríamos
determinar en el área de a b c b2
corchetes indican área y para determinar
el área de abc de pues podemos encontrar
el área de abc de a b c y sumarse la al
área de c d
a de c de a pero como a veces hice ideas
son congruentes entonces esta área es
igual a esta área y por lo tanto lo
podemos poner como dos veces el área de
c de a
del triángulo se dé a esto está
magnífico porque nosotros sí sabemos
calcular las áreas de los triángulos
entonces ahora nos vamos al triángulo
cede a trazamos trazamos esta altura y
va a bajar perpendicularmente supongamos
que aquí se llama h entonces lo que
tenemos que hacer es multiplicar bueno o
hacer dos veces dos veces la base del
triángulo cda por la altura dividirlo
entre dos y luego multiplicarlo por dos
bueno entonces el área de abc de abc d
es igual a este 2 se cancela con este 2
nos queda base por altura y en este caso
el lado cede el lado cede sería nuestra
base y está h si de alguna forma la
podemos determinar sería nuestra altura
y entonces el resultado está lindo
verdad nos dice que si de alguna forma
podemos determinar la altura entonces
basta a multiplicar la base por la
altura correspondiente y con eso
obtenemos el área y de hecho este
resultado podríamos girarlo o sea aquí
pusimos que la base fuera cede pero
podemos hacer que la base sea de déjame
hacer el dibujo nos quedaría como sin a
ver si queda bonito como algo así pero
algo para allá más o menos se va a
quedar un poquito chueco pero ni modo
algo de este estilo entonces estoy acá
es a b c y d nada más los gire y ccoo y
lo que estoy haciendo es que ahora a
desea la base a que sea la base y ahora
nos consideremos la altura de acá
a la altura de acá déjame llamarle le
voy a poner h 2 es más a la primera deja
de ponerle h 1
entonces aquí sería b por h1 que sería
igual a c d por h1 pero otra forma de
determinar el área es ahora trazando
esta diagonal hacer el área de estos dos
triángulos que nos queda simplemente
igual
no voy a poner con el color naranja
igual a b2 b1 b2 sería la base 2 que
sería de a de x
h 2 y entonces cualquiera de estas dos
fórmulas sirve para determinar el área
del paralelogramo para terminar nada más
déjame darte un ejemplo imagínate que
alguien llega y pinta el siguiente para
él logramos pitt al paralelogramo pues
este paralelogramo de acá nos dice que
la base mide 5 y que la altura mide 6 y
entonces si nos pide determinar que nos
pide determinar el el área de este
paralelogramo basta multiplicar 5 por 6
y bueno aquí aquí puse la altura fuera
verdad bajando desde este vértice pero
también podríamos pensarla desde acá y
esa misma altura también es 6 y por lo
tanto el área de este paralelogramo
sería igual a 30